[Music]
another setback for access to abortions
in the United States
on Friday a Texas federal judge
suspended the approval of an abortion
pill that has been safely used for
decades
after this decision a court in
Washington state ordered the federal
Food and Drug Administration to continue
making the medication available
to challenge the Texas ruling further
the Department of Justice issued a
statement saying it is committed to
protecting Americans access to Legal
reproductive care and will appeal the
Texas Court ruling
many say this is a dangerous precedent
for the Biden Administration this issue
has remained a priority
there is no question that the president
and I are going to stand with the women
of America and do everything we can to
ensure that women have the ability to
make decisions about their health care
their reproductive Health Care in a
manner that is is what they need and
they decide that not their government
last year the president signed an
executive order ensuring the protection
of women's right to access abortion
this came after the Supreme Court's
decision to overturn a constitutional
right to abortion
Friday's two court rulings mean the
future of the drug is uncertain many
fear this will increase the already
existing challenges faced by women in
some U.S states